whoa that's let's a high rating playing
grand master fard staff Anton demchenko
and I don't know that guy 26 that's
pretty high in the five-minute pool so
what do we get I played him once and
lost him no no particular memory button
Kim so let's play this and try to check
out what he is doing against the
exchange here exchange line it's not
very ambitious but very safe the only
problem is a forgotten most of it
especially if it's this kind of thing
that's not a super great line for black
but you can easily forget the details
okay if it takes only for I've ripped
the eight at the end that's very nice
forward okay he can take a phone now but
that's also something where a rather be
wide but this whole line isn't that
great for Black Sea six is not not so
reliable it's it's playable it's not
totally bad but it's not not really good
ideas 95 now which is pretty big threat
yeah this is what is thought was that
what is there what was there there was a
tricky am that I try to remember no g5
King g7 is not not helping him helping
much there was something with rook f8
that I tried to remember
that's not the position actually I
wonder 95 King g7 is there something
that I can do something something nice
he's threatening to move the rock of
course on something to keep in mind by
g5 King g7 that doesn't lead anywhere
right now before then is actually
blundering I can go h5 maybe h5 but
study moves the rook what about rook to
d6 look to d6 and I have to play
sometime ideas age 5 like a bishop e6 h5
maybe as a move like night before in
this position maybe
right before I can play Bishop be one
look at the moment cannot so easily be
in attack King g7 I just have bishop age
six winning a pawn now it's just a pawn
and the bishop is 6 i'll also have 95
that's it's quite interesting actually
maybe this is about h5 is probably just
stronger and it's not easy if I am now
look rookie success also Margie 5h takes
H takes you five check so he gives me
this pawn chair I wonder if this is the
best way to play I guess it is so I'm oh
wait wait a bit just not so quick what
about rook to rook f6 Bishop g4 check
King e6 it's probably not leading to
much yeah he has some some kind of
compensation possibly with night before
then move the bishop then rookie to win
this kind of things that that might be
might be possible so we should see two
looks normal look at what f95 that's
quite interesting so rookie 295 is good
and I'm threatening h5 in this position
I think trying to activate all the
pieces it's okay
so age five kingi son I don't have a I
don't have a good square mile of maracas
is actually a bit a bit in trouble
interesting okay maybe I have to go the
here g45 not ideal but how do I keep my
rook if I know don't do that and well I
have my my things my position pretty
well-organized f-4s covered so maybe
just here Knight e5 what this maybe they
sent that's not bad and then maybe 95
this is covered let's make it make a
safe move I think now it doesn't do
anything I know but I wasn't sure how to
improve this position maybe more like
this here before then bring the King up
he he cannot really do much IC 5 sort of
I should have prevented that I really
should have prevented that mmm not good
Bishop comes to be seven all of a sudden
hmm okay it should be four does he have
a bishop I can still take I can still
take okay now this is not not a trade
that I wanted really not he moves the
night I can take b7 my even look is
covered but that's not really not ideal
this whole thing
I can't remove that I don't know we
probably won't play it but ok he did oh
that's not that I did not see it all hmm
check Wow okay Wow okay seven king of
six and all of a sudden my stuff is
hanging 95 King f6 do you believe that
don't tell me I'm worse yet would be
really weird also not possible wow what
a move ranchi five also not on time
warning unbelievable really unbelievable
I'm not better here anymore not at all
Wow and how am I not worse takes here
it's not possible look amazing Wow
yeah and I'm just were sound amazing
yeah I mean I played some bad moves but
what a tactic what what's a tech tech
unbelievable ya ever just a crab endgame
now many ways I am defending badly but
I'm just too shocked Jeff what black was
essentially outplayed and then I let him
back into the game Wow but another
really great tactic Jeff yeah
unfortunately Jeff Jeff it's not so easy
for him to make any progress actually
check that's why I'm continuing a bit
there are offered I'm actually slower oh
ok there whatever all right what it i
just wanted to resign them if night x g5
what a tech deck ya qiao quarter and I
simply must win this game nothing more
nothing less check so his yeah I should
just win but I don't I mean okay it was
a series of of not so great moves I
didn't really see em something great
there so I played be three and this and
then I went here and now now I have to
be now I have to improve
we're around here it still should be
good I'd be five for the network was
also bad yeah why do I play be five in
this position I mean okay it's it's it's
really all about this tactic that he has
but of course I can take why don't that
take if I take and go here I'm still
completely in control him it's just one
point for nothing okay some of this yeah
that sets of course the great move I'm
just clearly worse after this it just
it's not just giving away advantage I'm
just clearly worse I mean I defended
badly being a bit under shock but
actually this is the relatively best
line chat here this is just crap really
is just bad those two pawns are bad and
this king is more active this is also a
weakness okay I defend it badly but I
don't think you can defend this probably
you cannot Wow can yeah I'm losing
here's this is really bad I also like I
cannot play h5 495 so this is this is
right but I really I really I need to
have something better simply something
better than even allowing this p65 stuff
but how do i do that i cannot don't get
age 5 in
there's probably nothing so clear I mean
I don't really see anything super
convincing this is slow and share could
have played before I merely if I wanted
yeah of course well here this is the
clear clear improvement if I take and go
here that that prevents all the other
the city tactics this is really just a
pawn and germ nothing more nothing less
but die chief life was great okay well
thanks for watching